so things looking pretty good so far
what do we want to do next
part c says reverse thrust is shut down
when the aircraft reaches a speed
of let's highlight this 36 meters per
second
how far so how far is a displacement
question
how far from the point of touchdown
correct to the nearest meter
does this happen well it seems like all
we need to do is to
very straightforwardly substitute
appropriate values into my
equation my model which i developed back
in part b
i'm trying to answer a question at x so
nicely i already have x being the
subject
and what i know is that velocity will be
36 at that point so i just need to
substitute in v equals 36
into here so let's see what we get when
we do that
and this is part c so i'm going to say
when
v equals 36
x is going to be equal to 207 plus 5 000
log of and then this seems to me like a
whole lot of
calculator work so let's go ahead and
pop this in here first
plus v squared uh sorry not v squared
i've got a substitute value for v which
is 36 so it's 36 squared down there
i'm going to reach over for a calculator
like so
okay let's have a look here some old
working i was doing there all right so
let's have a go with this
this is going to be 207
plus 5 000 i'm going to need my log
function here
i've got a fraction in there and it's 20
000
plus let's make it bigger 66
squared and then on the denominator 20
000
plus 36 squared all right what are we
getting here
so i'm reading my decimal places as
hundred and seventy eight point two nine
four eight dot dot dot if i go back to
the question
i'm pretty sure what accuracy do they
want they want
um correct to the nearest meter so
therefore down here
i'm just going to say therefore i can
move that aside it's going to be
rounding down
878 meters after touchdown
that's to the nearest meter
okay so happy times just a
straightforward use of the model that i
got
in part part b rather so we're finally
on the home stretch let's have a look at
the final
part of this question the brakes alone
are then used to reach the taxi speed
of seven meters so if you're not sure
what this is referring to you know when
the plane
touches down um seven meters per second
apparently is the speed that it's happy
to sort of just drive around
the runways um until it can you know get
to the airport terminal and then
disembark its passengers
how far from the point of touchdown
correct to the digimeter does the plane
reach
its taxi speed so when do we get to
um velocity equals seven now this has
been tricky right as we've gone through
we have um started with a model that was
from uh not to three uh not a three
seconds i should say for time
and then as we went into part b we kind
of abandoned that we knew that we were
going to be after time three
but then what we created was a model
that was uh independent of time it was a
displacement
velocity equation that we created so
when we have a think about how this is
going to progress
um you know even though in part a i said
oh here's what happens between time zero
and three
and then for part b i said here's what
happens after time
three um in part d i don't have a value
for like well what time
is this i know that the velocity wants
to get to
seven meters per second but i don't know
when that actually happens
and you can see the question sort of
doesn't care about the when
it says how far this is another x
question another displacement question
so what i'm going to do to make the
numbers easier for me and you can see as
i went through my my integrations here
right i had chosen values i'd chosen my
initial value and my origin as it were
to make my integrations and my constants
of integration very easy to evaluate
so i'm going to do something a little
bit sneaky here in part d
because the answer to part d doesn't
really care about the time
from the previous situations it just
cares about the displacement
relative to the previous situations i'm
going to do a sneaky thing and reset
time uh no this is not a trick that i'm
pulling out of um
a disney plus lucky series this is just
i can set t
equals 0 to be anything right and t
equals 0 is nice and convenient because
it makes my constants
easy to evaluate so what i'm going to do
and i need to introduce this right
because i'm sort of breaking the
continuity i have from the previous
parts of the question i'm going to say
consider a new scenario
where so i'm defining this very very
explicitly
where t is the number of seconds
and what i'm thinking about is what
defines this particular situation it's
not touchdown anymore if you go back to
the question
rather than now saying this t is from
point of touchdown
time in seconds after touchdown i'm
thinking about what happens
when the brakes alone are used again so
this is when the reverse thrust
shuts down okay we went from touchdown
which and then the brakes were going and
then we went to reverse thrust which was
part b
and then that was going for some amount
of time and then it says the brakes
alone are then used so reverse thrust is
finished
and i just use the brakes to get down to
this speed so then i'm going to
explain this as the number of seconds
after reverse thrust
ends
okay so now that i have defined this
right i can then say
in other words my new time equals zero
uh when is that and the answer is well
when did reverse
um thrust stopped and the answer is if
you have a look back at the question
reverse thrust is shut down when the
aircraft reached a speed of 36 that was
the whole reason why we found that in
part c
so reverse thrust is shut down at v
equals 36 so my new time
zero tells me that velocity equals 36
and similarly i also know where this
happens not just how fast i'm going but
part c
enabled me to find out that it's 878
meters
after touchdown so i've also got a value
for x it's 878 at least to the nearest
meter so now being that i'm back in sort
of the same kind of
force situation the same kind of
acceleration situation that i was back
in part a
i can say wait a second i already know
what x double dot is equal to
it's the same negative 2 without the
reverse thrust going on
that i had earlier so i'm going to
proceed again
and integrate up to velocity and
displacement in terms of time um i know
that seems a bit weird because my whole
answer is not in dependent on time but i
need to know what value of time will get
me to that particular
location that's the question right how
far so i'm going to say
integrating i'll go
integrating x dt equals the integral of
minus 2
oops you know z dt and what that's going
to give me is a velocity
expression so that's going to be minus 2
t
plus another constant what am i up to
now i just did
3 so i'm up to 4 now c4
and i'm going to use this condition up
here you can see when i put in
t equals 0 i'm going to get
c4 i'm going to say t equals 0 implies
that c4 is equal to
36 so that's just going to be my
velocity
expression just substituting that back
minus 2t plus
36 and then i integrate one more time
the integral with respect to
time to get up to displacement right so
this is going to be
integral of all of this
with respect to time that'll give me
displacement
uh what do i get here this looks
familiar minus t squared plus 36
t and then i hope i think this will be
my final constant of integration
so i've got c5 being some other
real number okay again when i put in at
time
equals zero and you're going to put in
this 878 which was where my reverse
thrust shut down i'm going to say t
equals 0
that implies that this constant is going
to be 878.
so what i got now a displacement
equation i'll just substitute that back
minus t squared plus 36t
plus 878
okay now how do i work out where things
are happening well i need to know at
what time
i get down to my breaks successfully
reduce me down
to 7 meters per second so you can see
right here
this is going to be i'll just highlight
it for you this is going to be
the equation that allows me to find a t
that corresponds to velocity
seven so i'm going to say when v equals
seven um i'm going to have minus 2t
plus 36 equals 7
from my velocity equation subtract 36
from both sides i think that gives me
negative 29.
t equals divide that through by negative
2 that gives me 14 and a half
i don't really care about that time i'm
just going to use it to substitute it
into
displacement so substituting
into displacement
what does that give me something awkward
because 14 and a half is a gross number
x equals negative 14 and a half
that's being squared plus 36
lots of 14 and a half plus that 878
let's reach for that calculator again
okay what do we get here so whoopsie
daisy let's put some brackets 14.5
that's going to get squared or it would
be get
squared if you put the 14 in there plus
36
lots of 14.5 and then what am i adding
878. so what am i getting
here of course i'm getting fairly round
numbers because
all of the decimals were approximated in
the previous step
but that is close enough for me again
i'm pretty sure i want it to the nearest
meter so i'm going to say
in other words 1 11
because that rounds up meters after
touchdown that's when i reach
taxiing speed so you can see my final
answer doesn't depend on time but i use
time as my stepping stone
to get there so this question um number
one it's a bit of a marathon trying to
go
all the way through there's quite a lot
that you've got to keep in your head
there's a lot of information that you
have to tease out as well that's sort of
tucked into the question
but the key thing here the most tricky
thing i think is that's part of this is
that the model
sort of changes as we define it for
different um
domains of time and then for different
like places right like
this this is when the reverse thrust
kicks in this is where it shuts down
and you have to have different models
that capture you at each of those
different points